we are talking about the Euler line
which is a special so to speak highway
for any triangle for any triangle you
can draw this Highway but you need to
identify some very special points for
the triangle you can do everything that
we talked about today using only a
straightedge with no markings and the
compass so these constructions are
called Euclidean constructions so let's
start with the first point well you can
take the midpoints of each of the sides
connect them to the opposite vertex this
segment here CD has a special name it's
called medium of the triangle okay so
how many minions we have is 3 the fact
that this worked for one triangle does
not guarantee that it will work for all
and so should they draw a lot of
pictures here and try on each of them or
should I use some technology let's use
technology to help us know experiment
having a different triangle well they
seem to intersect Oh fancy I can get
wild so it looks like any triangle we
will have those three segments
intersecting in a point
well that point turns out to be the
center of mass or our point which also
is known the central it or in Eastern
Europe it is known by the name MIDI
Center which simply says it's the centre
of the three medians
the other point will have some practical
implications if you have two villages
and you want to build a railroad so that
no matter where on this railroad you
build a station the people from the two
villages will walk the same distance to
that station it's called the
perpendicular bisector of segment a-b
hmm no matter where you are on this
railroad you build your station as
people from both villages will walk
exactly the same distance suppose you
have three villages which want to build
a school where will they build the
school so the kids from all three
villages work exactly the same distance
to the school if you want villagers from
A and B to walk the same distance then
you have to be on there perpendicular
bisector you can also say how about
being fair to villages C and a those
villagers have to walk on the
corresponding railroad the school shall
rebuild where the two perpendicular
bisectors intersect so if we call this o
OB is equal to oay
and Oh a is equal to OC this is
different to the middie centre yes it is
a very different one and it has a name
it's called the circumcenter because
they are referring to a circle whose
Center is O and that circle passes
through the three vertices right now the
circumcenter is inside the moment it
passes the triangle that triangle seems
to be a right triangle and this is true
now if we push the circumcenter out then
the triangle becomes obtuse and this is
a property which is true or any triangle
that may not be the most optimal
position for the three villages but if
you want to be fair to all three then
you may have to take it out if they form
an obtuse triangle which one is the
actual center of the triangle there is
no actual centre it depends on your
viewpoint so both of them deserve to be
called centers of the triangle so
derivative is base
times Heights also called altitude / -
all right so let's locate this height we
need to drop a perpendicular from Point
C to side a B there's your right angle
I'm so good I can do it from any
position I'm just kidding overturn it
guess what happens
those three altitudes intersect in a
point that point usually denoted by H is
called the orthocenter of the triangle
and in mathematics when you say that
some objects are orthogonal some lines
you really mean that they are
perpendicular
so we're intersecting the three
perpendiculars or the three altitudes in
this triangle and again they happen to
intersect in the same point so now we
want to again check if this is not a
coincidence so let us use our magic
software yes we will move it around now
watch what will happen with this
orthocenter as I try to get it next to
see that triangle will be right so you
can push the orthocenter out but it will
again happen when the triangle is obtuse
so that's the third coincidence we have
seen we have three different centers we
are wondering which one is the most
important there is no good answer to
that question which is your favorite the
centroid so now what do you think what
do you like the centroid ah because oh
there's something we didn't prove this
guy a G - G is like two to one it's
twice as long and the same thing happens
on the other medians so they are all in
ratio two to one this is a property
which was part of the regular geometry
program in Bulgarian maybe eighth or
ninth grade and I remember it's proof
with similar triangles and I was
astounded how you can prove such
complicated facts using basic geometric
tools okay so now if you are brave
enough to draw all three in a single
picture okay well I'm just going to
basically close my eyes and draw three
points will those three points lie on a
special clay
oh well with you they probably we're
probably well let's try okay I'm just
gonna do it on the side okay huh
almost okay I think you have to do it
even with your eyes closed give you
perfect mathematics ready here we go
okay Brady is at Mt auto shop to put
three points he almost got them in a
very special position but not quite but
not any three random points it's rarely
beyond a line very rarely that's a very
special case in fact of probability zero
how about the three centers are they in
some general position to each other or
are they relatives of each other they
are related somehow so you have the
Medicentre
the circumcenter and the orthocenter you
have the three medians the three
perpendicular bisectors and the three
altitudes let's simplify it so we are
looking only at these three points let's
see what is happening so now let's see
if these three centers indeed always lie
on this line they look like it oh no
matter what the triangle is no matter
how we pull these points apart the three
centers seem always to lie on the line
and the theorem says that the three
centers of a triangle circumcenter mid
center and orthocenter always lie on a
single line called the Euler line there
are lots of things that turn out to be
true once you know that there is this
line there are the centers in the
triangle also defined using certain
rules that happen to lie on this line
and so this line turns out to be sort of
a highway for the triangle there is one
very important center called the
in-center which almost never lies on
this line it refuses to lie there so
let's look at it we will attempt to draw
a circle which is inside and it touches
each of the sides what you do is you
draw the angle bisector of angle a you
draw the angle bisector of angle B and
the angle bisector of angle C they
intersect in a point the center of a
circle which touches the three sides of
the triangle so again the question is
does this incident rely on our highway
let's check on the computer off the line
it wants to be on the line but we are
not managing now watch what will happen
win ah this is it this is not just any
triangle it is an isosceles triangle and
so the Euler line in this case has is
through vertex E and it is the median
altitude and perpendicular bisector Plus
as a bonus the angle bisector of angle C
so it is all of those and therefore it
will pass for this in Center 2 if it is
the angle bisector but this happens only
if the triangle is isosceles and that's
not easy to prove what is the highway
the Euler line for an equilateral
triangle so this is the only case where
all of the centers collide in one and
you cannot draw a line it's just a point
from now on once you see a special point
for triangle you can always ask the
question does this point lie on the
Euler line or not 1/4 of the big one and
you can see it siblings on the sides is
all congruent for congruent triangles so
what is happening here